hello everyone and the yes I promise
this is the last video I'll be uploading
today but we have to check out the
fourth game of the rapid section of the
world facial random championship this
time crossing with the white pieces
against Caruana with the black pieces of
Fabiano when got right back into the
match with a with a very nice miniature
in the previous round now let's see what
happens here so cross and with the white
pieces open the width d4 in the previous
game if you remember we saw efore in the
e5 now we have d 4 + f5 sort of a
Fischer random Dutch with b3 Magnus or
opens up the dark square Bishop and
Knight to g6 we have nice to d3 Knight
now nicely controls a c5 in the e5 and
now b6 Fabi opens up his light square
bishop we have castles Queen side
castles that is by Magnus and now Knight
to d6 freeing up the square for his King
to be able to castle with f3 and now
comes queenside castle by Fabi as well
Knights the g3 and here comes f4 it's a
very interesting idea and it's basically
where our game begins here at 5 Bobby
really takes you know the adventurous
path into this game he pushes f4 we have
night - h5 and now queen - d5 so he
sacrifices the f4 pawn for some rapid
development so let's see what he had in
mind Knight captures on h4 by Magnus we
have Knight captures on f4 and the night
the other night also captures on f4 the
queen is under attack so Magnus grabs
upon Queen to a5 now going after the a
to pawn but here across and replies with
E for so what's the idea can Cora wanna
grab the a to pawn
well yes and no because if Queen
captures in a tube then Magnus head in -
Bishop the c3 and now the idea is king D
2 followed by rook to a1 trapping the
Queen and the Queen doesn't really have
a good way out so what what you could
play here is e 5 and then after King to
be too threatening rook to a1 now you go
he captures on d4 Queen captures on d4
and now Queen to a3 you escape this way
but it comes over you know with a price
rook day 1 you have to go to c5 now we
have it
here captures captures and now you lose
the a 7-point so you don't really grab
upon by grabbing upon
so not Queenie to rather with E 5 by
Fabi and knock D captures on e5 with
Knight to f7 preparing to recapture with
the knight on e5 and now King to b1
Magnus no longer allows Queen captures
on a2 and Bishop to b4 first attacking
the rook we have broke the e2 putting
both rooks and lights worse Knight
captures on e5 and now Quinta III Magnus
finally brings the Queen into the game
with Bishop to c5 pushing the Queen back
Queen d2 offering the Queen trade and
now Bishop to b4 again attacking the
cross and Queen Queen to c1 and now
brush up to a3 and here across and just
blocks at Bishop here with Bishop
captures Queen captures and the Queen to
c5 and now Magnus doubles up on the D
file so for the moment Carson has
excellent development and the fabi's
pawn sacrifice hasn't really paid off in
just yet we have a 5 Bobby starts the
attack now and we have Knight to d5 by
Magnus and excellent outpost for the
night if you want to get rid of it you
have to give up your light square bishop
which is something you don't want to do
as then Magnus gets all over the light
squares for himself so Bishop to c6
preparing to bring the King into the
game this way and then bring the rook
over to the a file perhaps start pushing
the a pawn we have a three by Magnus
preparing B for King to be 7 and now B
for not allowing Fabi to go along with
his plan 8 captures a captures and now
Queen although all the way back to f8
Knight back to e3
opening up now the default for across
and rooks and now d6 with nice to see
for offering a trade here and now rook
to a 8 Fabi now will attempt the double
rocks and the a file so you can activate
both the rooks but now b5 we have Bishop
to d7 and here Carlsen waits no longer
he plays Knight captures on d5 with
check so you have to accept accept the
knight sacrifice otherwise you're just
gonna lose material we have pawn
captures and the rook captures on d6 and
here the situation on the clock is
Crossin is down on time he's three and a
half minutes Fabi six minutes but across
and is on the attack and here
you don't well it's not all that easy to
defend the three is just rock captures
here so you'd win two pieces for the
rook
even though okay you sacrificed a piece
so basically it would be down the
exchange but what you really want to
prevent this Queen d4 so what you maybe
could place rook to a four to take away
the d4 square from White's Queen but
then it just allow this
so Fabi I decided he doesn't like Bishop
the CIT as you are saving the bishop but
then you get Queen d4 and you don't have
a way of defending against Queen to b6
it would just be very ugly you have to
play rock a7 clear the a square for the
King so far we decided to do that right
away he played rook to a7 and now Magnus
takes the two pieces rook captures with
check and Knight captures with captures
with check King to be eight and now
capture son a7 with King captures an a7
and now Bishop to c4 preparing Bishop to
d5 to really try and finish off this
attack but Fabi is able to consolidate
he plays Queen to c5 attacks the bishop
here and now Carlsen doesn't like Queen
captures and g7 which is which is
definitely a good move for example if
Queen captures on g7 you could block
with rook to e7 but then you can go from
back Queen to b2 and now it's it's a bit
funny because if Queen captures Bishop
then you get to Queen eight recheck and
you pick up the rook but with a little
time on the clock you know you don't
always find such a nifty resources so
bush up to d5 by Magnus first and now
look the e7 by Fabi guarding the pawn
here we have Queen to a2 with check King
to be 8 and now Queen to a 8 with check
King c7 and now Queen to c6 with check
and this is just this is just a great
moment in the game crossing sacrificed
first the piece then after he grabbed
two pieces for the rook he was basically
down the exchange and here he just
decides that you know trading Queens is
good for him so he plays Queen to c6
width check we have Queen captures with
you know removing check B captures and
c6 and now rook to e5 so here Magnus
says a beautiful pawn chain here and
he's definitely other material he has
six points Fabi only has three so white
is better here
but okay for a moment this bishop is
basically a pawn in interchange so you
have to start pushing or those points so
f4 by Magnus we have moved to h5 and now
h3 a rope to h4 trying to get somehow
activate this rook f5 now we have rook
to f4 and here Magnus is down to one
minute Fabi still has two minutes on two
minutes on the clock and the g4 by
Magnus so if you go after the h3 point
which is what Magnus wants you to do
then Magnus gets the bush ii v f6 and so
on if you go after the h3 pawn but it's
hard to find any other moves Fabi plays
h6 but now c4 pushing even more pawns
further and now troop to f3 going after
this pawn as you don't really have a
have any any other ideas with E 5 now
Magnus and now comes rope captures on h3
with f6 now just trying to create a
passport either by capturing here then
it's just game over you cannot allow
this
so we have G characters he captures and
now rook to e3 and here f7 so it's a
protected passed pawn there's if it's
anyone who can win this game it's white
but black still has a rook so maybe he
can hold on to this we have looked at a
one with check King to see - and now
rook the f1 not allowing f8 to just
queen but now what do you do
so Carlsen starts bringing the King into
the game King ds3 we have King to d6
blocking and now kink the e4 Bobby goes
rook to f6 and now you can feel free to
pause the video and try to find a nice
idea for Magnus in this position while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on being such an
excellent and game player and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
you could go king to e3 and we go around
for a bit but in the end it all comes
down to this move c7 so congratulations
to everyone who found that now you're
just threatening to either Queen the
pawn or when the e5 square for king of
course Fabi had the capture it
now comes King to e5 the rook is under
attack rook has to go back rook to f1
and here King to e6 so what would you
play here King to d8 by Fabi but now
efore and it was after the 54 that
Fabi resigned the game Fabiana Corwin
resigned the game and this means he is
out of the world official random
championship because the result at the
moment is 12 and a half to seven and a
half and out of the 24 possible points
Carson already has 12 and a half that's
over a half so we will not be going into
the blade section because you only get
one point for a win in the blade section
so here he resigns because well if you
don't do anything then white will just
go back up the five block the rook and
the next move you're just gonna Queen
the pawn you cannot move the rook
because just f8 Queens the pawn with
check so here you can just waste a move
but like I said better about five and
it's all over rocky - King f6 and next
movie just Queen the pawn there's a
there's nothing you can do here you
could try something like this to give up
the rook and maybe maybe try and do
something about the bishop but it is
just pointless it's completely winning
for white so of course Fabi knows this
and after Bishop play d4 he resigned the
game so Carlsen versus Cora wanna ends
in 12 and a half seven and a half Fabi
got two very nice wins in but in the end
Magnus was able to advance to the finals
I will not mention who he will be facing
in the finals as I'm planning to show
some more games tomorrow from the net
overseas Wesley so match but if you're
really interested you can always check
for it yourselves online so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank dog McNab for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
world fish random championship checking
up on the 22nd european team
championship and of course and your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day